hi i'm mike coleman a developer advocate
at google cloud
and today i want to talk about some key
considerations you should be aware of
when looking to migrate
existing applications from vms to
containers
using migrate for anthos
[Music]
in a couple of our earlier videos on
migrate for anthos we covered how to use
the discovery tool
to discover what applications are a good
fit for migration
if you've not checked those out you may
want to watch them and come back
you can find the links in the
description below for the remainder of
this video
i'm going to assume that you've already
chosen an application
run the discovery tool and found that
your application is well suited for
migration
while this is a great place to be there
are some additional questions you'll
want to answer before proceeding
with a migration what should i do with
any databases i might be using
how should i handle a vm with multiple
applications running in it
how do my networking requirements
translate to a kubernetes deployment
let's start by looking at handling
multiple apps or services
running in a single vm
a common scenario we often see is an
application where multiple components
are running on the same vm
for instance perhaps you have a web
front end a middleware component
and a database all running together in a
monolithic virtual machine
now ideally with kubernetes you have a
single process running in each pod
however by default migrate for antholos
will not create a separate container
image for each service running in a vm
since migrate for anthos will try to
migrate each running service
what you do in a situation where you
have multiple application components
is to ensure that only one is running
when you
run the migration process for instance
shut down the middleware and the
database run migrate for anthos and
capture the web front end
then shut down the web front end and the
database
one migrate for athos and capture the
middleware
with those two components migrated into
containers you'll need to decide
what makes the most sense for your
database
with the database tier you first need to
decide whether or not you're dealing
with a mission critical component
in some cases you might be migrating or
configuring a dev test deployment
of your application or perhaps your
production application is configured as
a monolith
and you don't want to break out the
separate components now you realize of
course that this configuration doesn't
offer you the ability to easily scale or
provide fault tolerance
but it works for what you're trying to
accomplish
in this case you would use migrate for
anthos to migrate the data to a
persistent volume
attach that volume to the pod at the
appropriate spot in the file system
if it's possible to migrate your
database to cloud sql that's a great
choice
you can use google cloud's database
migration service to migrate the data
then configure your application to use
cloud sql or other managed database
service
from there you can start to benefit from
the advantages of running your database
on a managed service offering
now if cloud sql is not a fit then your
next option could be to run your
database natively
on kubernetes you would build a cluster
and install and configure the database
software using kubernetes stateful set
and persistent volumes then use migrate
for anthos to export the data from the
vm
to the new database finally if running
the database on kubernetes is not a good
fit
you could migrate the database tier into
a google cloud compute engine vm
using migrate for compute engine there's
a great blog post up on our site
providing some additional details on how
to decide
where to run your database we'll put the
link in the description below
now that you have individual images for
each of your services you'll want to
think about networking
in many cases different services within
an application are accessed using a dns
based
resource name however when migrating to
kubernetes
you'll use a service name a good
recommendation is to choose
short yet descriptive service names and
ensure your services are
all running in the correct kubernetes
namespace
one way to handle the move from dns
names to service names
is to provide your service names via a
kubernetes config map
so let's take a look at using that
config map to alter the service
discovery so i have an application that
i've migrated over
a service in an application so if i do a
get services here
you'll see this ledger monolith service
that came from a virtual machine using
migrate for anthos
but i have not changed the dns mapping
to kubernetes service mapping so it
doesn't work
so i'm going to go ahead and go in and
we're going to open the editor
and we're going to edit the config map
and we're just going to remove these dns
suffixes
so when we do that that will take that
from being a dns based
name to the kubernetes service name
which is ledger monolith
service so let me do this last one here
and then we'll save that out and move
back to our terminal
and let's clear the screen and we're
going to go ahead and apply the config
map
and that's going to update the services
and how they communicate
so if we clear that now what we need to
do is we need to restart our pods and
we'll do that by deleting them
and then they'll recreate automatically
so we'll delete them
and then let's come up and let's watch
those pods get reloaded
and this will take a second so i've sped
up the video
and then now we can bounce out here and
let's take a look at our services
and make sure we've got the right ip
address so we'll do a get service
and there's that ip we'll move up here
into our browser we'll do a refresh
and you can see that it's actually
working now so that is
using a config map to move from dns
based name resolution with a virtual
machine
to kubernetes service based name
resolution using the internal kubernetes
service discovery mechanisms
as an aside when dealing with sensitive
configuration data
you'll want to take advantage of
kubernetes secrets
for instance if you need to provide a
password to connect to the database
you can store that in a kubernetes
secret rather than in a configmat
check the kubernetes documentation for
more information on how to configure and
use secrets
now the next thing to consider is
controlling access to your application
by default the deployment spec generated
by migrate for anthos contains a
suggested headless service object of
type cluster ip
this means no load balancing and a
single cluster internal ip reachable
only from within that cluster
in the case of our web front end service
we'd want to change that to the type
load balancer to allow
external access you should also consider
using some of kubernetes network policy
features
to restrict access to your various
application tiers
for instance you might want to use
network policies that allow only the web
front end to talk to the middleware tier
and another policy that allows only the
middleware tier to talk to the database
we've hit a few of the highlights with
regards to things you should consider as
you plan your vm migration using migrate
for anthos
to learn more about migrate from those
be sure to check out the migrate for
anthos documentation
and this is one video in a series so be
on the lookout for other my great
franco's videos
and like and subscribe to be notified as
we add additional content